embarrassment remembering that all be
dead soon is the most important tool
I've ever encountered to help me make
the big choices in life because almost
everything all external expectations all
pride all fear of embarrassment or
failure these things just fall away in
the face of death leaving only what is
truly important whilst nobody in last
week I saw a woman pushing herself to do
something she had never done before she
was trying to land 180 degree jumps but
she kept falling and falling and falling
eventually she landed one and then fell
again but she didn't give up trying I
thought to myself wow so cool I want to
try it and then I thought I hope nobody
sees me when I fall the fear public
embarrassment almost held me back from
trying it almost made me stop pushing
myself to be better and instead stay
mediocre almost I realized that I didn't
know any of the other people on the hill
and they wouldn't care if I fell I
realized that they get to my skill level
now I fell a lot and nobody laughed at
me I realized that I was watching this
woman in admiration and that people
looking on would secretly be cheering
for me instead of mocking me so I went
for it
and after a few Falls I landed my first
180 degree jump and it felt awesome when
you push through something scary it
builds you up and helps you grow when
you run from something scary you live
with regret and lose confidence if you
want to do something but you don't
because you're afraid of being
embarrassed and falling just go for it
people won't care if you don't make it
you'll grow stronger for stretching your
comfort zone you won't look back and say
I wish I give it a shot and you've got
people silently cheering you on
including me
so start belief